not many college football writers will
go to Purdue and somehow come out with a
story but pad 40 going to Purdue today I
don't know how you do it
you got Notre Dame tomorrow what do you
why are you going to Purdue I'm taking
on that daunting assignment of trying to
find something interesting at Purdue
well Jeff Brohm new coach there I think
he's one of the real up-and-coming
offensive minds in the game and he's got
both of his brothers on his staff I've
got kind of a little family oligarchic
going on there so we'll see if that
turns into a story what is the storyline
this year in college football you know I
I think it's whether Clemson can really
establish itself as an enduring dynasty
type school and perhaps challenge
Alabama's the premier program in the
country I did question of courses can
you deal without a the best quarterback
in your school history in deshaun Watson
a alabama is going to be there I think
we're all pretty sure that although
they're replacing most of their defense
can Clemson you know be in the top five
top ten and be in the picture as well
they'll find out pretty quickly they
play Auburn's second week at Louisville
third weeks and then they've got the big
showdown with Florida State late in the
season but I think Clemson staying power
is of interest to me I know you went to
USC recently I feel like sometimes when
you have a marquee quarterback we
somehow overrate just how good you're
going to be I loved Arnold I just don't
know if they're on the national the
national stage where everybody expects
them to be tell me differently I think
that's a legitimate question because I
think you know a boy college football is
the ultimate what was the last memory we
have of you sport in terms of carry over
to the next year and darn 'old was was
tearing up the Rose Bowl and they were
beating Penn State in that epic game you
got your quarterback back Penn State has
their quarterback and running back back
and everybody saw they're going to be
great well they both got some some major
holes to fill you know USC needs new
receivers they've got some some people
that need to step up defensively so I
think that there are legitimate
questions there but
I can't wait to see Darnell play again
sat down with him last week as you said
really just a cool guy place the
quarterback position differently than
most people I've seen he's got that real
just kind of flair to make stuff up on
the fly sometimes drives his coaches a
little bit crazy I think because he
doesn't just drop and put his foot in
the ground and grow like Tom Brady but
so you know Brett Favre and John Elway
did it that way and they were pretty fun
to watch and I make Sam Donald's kind of
cut from that cloth
I watched the Rose Bowl again that that
game is unbelievable it really is I mean
I know sometimes when we have a great
finish in a game then we say oh that was
a great game I mean they couldn't do
anything with Berkeley the Penn State
matching them it was just Evan flow
that's one of the greatest games I've
ever seen it really is I live here for
it and people were like yeah people were
like why did you go because it's not in
the playoff well I thought okay well
whoever wins this game is going to say
we should have been in the playoffs I
figured that's that's the column but
then you end up sitting there watching
this is ridiculous classic game as you
said I mean in the third quarter was
this Penn State Avalanche in the fourth
quarters this USC rally it was
tremendous YUM my daughter went to the
game and took a picture and she normally
leaves it at halftime and I told her
you're at the game do not leave that
game and then the game is over with and
she said I guess that was a really good
game dad right she knows nothing about
football except honey that's one of the
greatest games you'll ever see even
though you have no idea what you just
saw we're talking to Pat 40 Yahoo Sports
yeah my kids know nothing my son does a
little bit about sports but my
daughter's they have no idea no idea
about I'm with you my youngest daughter
is the same way she's getting ready to
go to Stanford and I told her you know
what you're going to watch a great
football program stuff that's nice I
mean like no idea well I my kids go to a
game and then my daughter takes pictures
of guys who are drunk and so she's
watching the Patriots in Carolina and
one of the greatest Superbowl finishes
of all time she's taking pictures of
drunk guy so her her camera has pictures
she said all that's Mike and that's
Tommy and that's Jim so she took
pictures of them instead of watching the
football game
all right we we had nick saban on
yesterday and Nick was he was fun
engaging I did ask him about being
overrated and he said yeah I probably am
the CBS poll he says he gets too much
credit there I don't look at heart I
think a hard ball is over covered I
don't think he's overrated so I blame
the media for that Saban is underrated
in my opinion what did you make of the
information it came out of that
anonymous poll yeah I'm with you I I
don't think he's overrated in the
slightest that's absurd I I don't even
see how you could possibly look at Nick
Saban and say he's even slightly
overrated yeah I think your
characterization of hardball is dead-on
over covered as much as anything and he
plays to that you know he will do he
will he will stir it up just you know
out of the blue was something here
something there so he understands kind
of how to manipulate that mechanism and
I obviously thinks it's good for
recruiting and probably good for ziggo
as well but I don't think he's overrated
I think he's an excellent coach if you
can do what he did at Stanford and then
turn around and do it at the 49ers and
now do it at Michigan
he's absolutely not overrated my opinion
but I mean saving is the gold standard I
agree I suppose her but Myers close but
not that close really I think Saban is
very much on a pedestal on his own at
this point do you believe Brian Kelley
is on the hunt seeded Notre Dame yes and
no I mean they can't go four and eight
again absolutely can't do that six and
six would not be good if you're eight
and four or better I think he's okay
Jack Swarbrick wants to keep it he
really does and they they retool the
staff and Swarbrick was very much a part
of the retooling retooling of the staff
and making this get to a place where
Kelly feels like they can win and turn
it around right now they've recruited
extremely well they've got you know good
player on top a good player at most
positions now they've just got to get
out of their own way stop beating
themselves in games and and hopefully
get some luck with injuries because the
last couple years have been hard on them
from that standpoint
sneaky team this year that could spoil
something
you know why I think Oklahoma State
could end up in the playoff I don't know
whether they've been talked about enough
this month that they may no longer be
sneaky but I think they could win the
big 12 Mike Gundy of all people is now
like the the guy in that conference but
if you want sneaky I think how about
Northwestern to make the big 10
championship game I think Northwestern
could could win the West got a
quarterback who's getting better and
better in Clayton Force and although the
NFL guys are interested in him Justin
Jackson outstanding running back and
just a lot of experience on both sides
of ball Pat Fitzgerald's kind of I think
overdue to break through and I think the
Western Division as usual is a bit a bit
open there in the big 10 closer to a
playoff berth Northwestern or Notre Dame
well we're a Big Ten West theoretically
you're in the big 10 championship that
puts you pretty close but still now I'll
say Notre Dame ok being politically
correct you're you're afraid there
because you're going to Notre Dame
tomorrow I see what you did give me this
give me this sneaky college town for
tailgating my gameday experience and
don't give me the obvious ones like LSU
or you know Michigan or Ohio State right
right a gallon I you know what I I'll
tell you this Mississippi State has
become like the loudest Stadium in
America and they have a let they get
those cowbells ringing about three hours
before kickoff out in the parking lots
you go through a game there you come out
of there you cannot hear for about a day
and a half it is unbelievable look you
know they had put all these restrictions
on when you can use the cowbells yeah
those were ignored they use them all the
time I got my Mississippi State cowbell
right here if you go more cowbell Dan
yeah so you can't go wrong with more
cowbell good luck with the travels
they're great to talk to you again we'll
check in with you during the season
sounds good man thank you that's Pat 40
Yahoo Sports national college football
and basketball columnist always fun to
talk to him the Dan Patrick show week
things on audience